No. No, no, no --
Wait, wait, wait.
Dude, not -- It's...
[ Inhales deeply ]
[Bleep] okay.
You're scaring me.
I-I didn't want to tell you
when we were in here.
All right,
all right.
I-I was going
to tell you today.
Um, I got accepted
to an artists'
residency program
in Boulder...
Colorado.
And I'm gonna go.
I was, um,
gonna sell my shit
and use this
as an opportunity to move.
[ Breathing heavily ]
What...
Ilana!
...the [bleep]...
Dude? Ilana?
...are you
talking about?!
Ow!
Ilana, um...
We need to get you
into therapy today.
This is an emergency,
okay?!
This is an emergency!
Okay, fun fact-o,
Ilana --
Did you know that
you could fly to Boulder
on a connecting flight
through O'Hare
with a layover
in Pittsburgh for $42?
I mean --
I had never looked up
how to fly to "Boulder."
Ew!
All right, all right.
O'Hare?!
Let's just --
I don't know
what that is!
Is that Gaelic?!
This is a little --
Google,
what is Boulder?!
[ Man moans ]
Jesus!
-No!
-God.
You didn't even tell me
you were applying.
Do you not consider me someone
to talk shit through with?
Are we not partners
in that way?
Of course I do, Ilana.
You're my only friend.
Well, I guess you've been
stuck with me for awhile,
but not anymore.
[ Broken glass crunches ]
No, dude, no.
I-I don't feel that way.
Ilana, wait.
Just wait.
[ Organ music playing ]
Oh, my goodness.
Ilana?
[ Chuckles ]
Yeah. Vulva.
You have ruined
the best part
of this interactive production
for me.
Not now.
I'm sorry, dude.
I-I'm sorry.
I feel really stuck in my life
right now, okay?
Nope. Nothing.
I need a change.
This is just like
you with grad school.
I mean, you were settling
into a track
and figuring out
your career.
Yeah, but I picked
a school in New York.
I factored you in.
I always factor you in.
Otherwise, I would've talked
to you about it.
I know.
I-I know.
I-I'm sorry.
Well, does -- does
anybody else know?
I mean, I just talked to my mom
and -- and your mom.
You told my mom?!
That is
so violating to me.
Ugh!
I'm sorry.
Just hold on a second.
Ilana?
[ Eerie music playing ]
♪♪
[ Sighs ]
What a bitch.
[ Slurps ]
Ilana, come on.
I...can...not believe...
that you would
not tell me this shit
if there was even
a chance of you going.
Dude, I was scared.
I-I mean,
I'm still scared.
Do you think that
I want to leave you?
[ Scoffs ] No, I almost wish
I didn't even get in
so I wouldn't even
have to do this.
Ha ha ha.
Like you're not
gonna get in
to some art program
you apply to.
You are the best artist
in the world
of all time!
No, I'm not.
Are you kidding me?
I need to go out
and do this thing
and -- and have an audience
that's more than just you
and -- and my parents.
This is the first opportunity
I have had
to finally
live and breathe art
rather than
breathing in,
like, leftover
prosciutto-wrapped dates
that I stole
from my catering gig.
They're so good,
though.
Yeah, I know. That's why
I continually take them,
but, I mean,
then rats come,
and I just, like, haven't
figured out how to --
It wouldn't be an issue
and you wouldn't
have to leave New York
if you just flushed them
down the toilet
or wrapped them
in tinfoil
and then put them
in a five-gallon Ziploc.
It's not about me not knowing
how to flush them.
It's not about that.
I mean, it is a teeny bit
about, like,
the methodical
strategies
in which
we have to avoid rats.
For the past
eight years,
I have cleaned out
hundreds of people's pubes
out of toilet bowls.
So many strangers --
so many --
have thrown up on me.
You do get thrown up on
an exorbitant amount.
Yeah.
Dude,
I am 30 years old.
I'm done
with New York.
[ Exhales deeply ]
Yeah.
I get it.
I'm really sorry.
I'm sorry.
I'm really --
I'm gross.
I made this all about me,
and it's not about me.
But I thought
you would've told me,
but, you know,
I just need time.
I need time
to process this, I --
process the thought
of you leaving.
Once I have that
for a few months,
[sighs] you know, whatever --
see my therapist,
double up
for a little while,
and -- and push it through
a little bit.
Just a little time,
and it'll be okay.
I'll be there to support you,
I promise.
So, speaking of --
Sorry.
Speaking of time...
Speaking of --
Uh, speaking of time...
[ Breathes shakily ]
[ Clears throat ]
So, the -- the program
starts in two weeks.
[ Ominous music playing ]
♪♪
What...are...you
talking about?!
[ Clattering ]
Don't leave!
Oh, my God.
Stop doing this.
We've had years together,
bitch!
You crazy [bleep] bitch!
Holy shit.
What are you
talking about?!
Ilana, stop.
Ilana?
[ Screams ]
[ Crowd gasps ]
[ Rustling, applause ]